sister thank you very much indeeda for
this meeting just a few brief points
first of all only 13 of the world
population
lives in under Democratic regime in
other words
there is a huge pressure on the model
that we want to defend and we know that
of course this war that's been triggered
against Ukraine it's against a
population against the people against
the democratic values that we defend
it's against the freedom against dignity
against human rights around which we are
united the European Union and the
accounts of Europe and this is why this
meeting this declaration is of huge
importance to underline the strength of
our commitment and there's another key
point I'd like to make this is sort of
the Cornerstone which is the rule of law
and the independence of the Judiciary
and the freedom of the press and of
course with this in mind the European
Union is trying to strengthen what it
has
and that is a decision to make certain
funding conditional on compliance with
the rule of law and this is we want to
impose very high standards on our
members
another example the first three years is
the annual report on the state of the
rule of law in the member states and the
most recent that was published in July
2022 and this also contains
recommendations for the individual
countries so there are constant efforts
that need to be made here I'd like to
say one other thing and say this quite
uh determinedly as well I think we all
know very well around the table that
there is sort of a deathly poison
against democracy and this uh poison is
this deadly cocktail of corruption and
disinformation and we know in a number
of countries there's a business model
with oligarchs who are often very close
to Russia and they purchase media
outlets and they purchase and they buy
off politicians and they promote a
disinformation and destabilizing
information there's an antidote to this
and the antidote is the independence of
the Judiciary it's the rule of law to
guarantee the quality of
non-discrimination to ensure that this a
deadly cocktail this threat and this
poison can be offended offer and I'd
like to be conclude by making two
operational points we'd like to
strengthen cooperation with accounts of
Europe and this is why we're currently
at the European Union signing up to the
European convention on human rights I'm
quite optimistic they will be able to
resolve the last few difficulties we
have with this and we're currently also
signing up to the Istanbul convention
the Swedish prisons I'd like to collect
congratulate them it was working ever so
hard to ensure we could meet the subject
of the next few weeks thank you very
much indeed
musician and next is the president of
the European commission Ursula from The
Lion
thank you very much Catherine and dear
colleagues
we should never forget that the first
summit of the Council of Europe gathered
30 years ago after the fall of the Iron
Curtain
when all of Europe United around the
founding principles of this Council all
of Europe agreed that working together
to promote Democratic Values is the best
way to promote peace in Europe
because and this is right war is
unthinkable
in the community of like-minded
democracies
Today We Gather against the backdrop of
Russia's war of aggression against
Ukraine Russia refuses to recognize the
Democratic right of ukrainians to be the
master of their own future
everything we stand for in this Council
of Europe
it is an attack against the founding
principles
the more important is that we join
forces to protect and nurture and Foster
democracy we all stand by Ukraine
the perpetrator has to be account held
accountable and therefore the register
of Damages can and will play an
important role
but fostering democracy of course begins
at home
democracy is never for granted
it's a constant work in progress
and the risk of democratic backsliding
is real
this is why in the European Union we are
monitoring the state of the rule of law
in all member states every single year
we also put forward new initiatives for
the equality of all citizens
new rules to fight corruption
and for the very first time a media
Freedom Act
cooperation with the Council of Europe
plays a big role in this work for
democracy
so today I want to confirm the European
Union's intention to join the European
convention on human rights as soon as
possible
we want to strengthen our Union's
Democratic foundations like never before
finally
with the backdrop of Russia's War
the last year has marked a turning point
in many countries
passed towards the European Union
from the Western Balkans to Ukraine to
Moldova to Georgia
we are standing strong together and
therefore I see room for an even closer
cooperation and partnership between the
European Union the Council of Europe and
each candidate country
so that the story of European democracy
will be continued to be written in
Ukraine and elsewhere in our continent
thank you very much
thank you Ursula and now we have
foreign
[Music]